[Music]
Breaking Bad is definitely a landmark in
TV history to someone who grew up
watching the serials of the 1960s a show
with that level of technical and
thematic complexity would be somewhat
surprising there's no doubt that
television as an art form has grown and
improved over time through continuous
experimentation with the format Breaking
Bad didn't come out of nowhere Vince
Gilligan and the writers of Breaking Bad
built on the work of the great shows
before them to make something that took
full advantage of what makes television
unique since its inception the rules of
television forced producers to adapt to
the unusual nature of the format unlike
movies TV competed directly with other
shows changing your mind was as easy as
pressing a button
borrowing techniques from serial and
radio TV writers fought for the
attention of viewers in a way movies
didn't have to early TV show runners
used cliff hangers to ensure viewers
kept coming back to appease shorter
attention spans every show had its own
contained episodic narrative structure
be sure to be with us again next week at
the same time
what makes Breaking Bad so
groundbreaking in particular is how it
took the constraints of the format and
use them to its advantage cliff hangers
became an opportunity for the show to
reflect groundbreaking character changes
an episodic narrative structure means
that the show is rich with short stories
that stick with the viewers and deepen
our understanding of the characters many
episodes are self-contained stories that
don't directly move the plot forward but
give us insight into character dynamics
and indirectly raise the stakes for the
show as a whole most importantly
Breaking Bad took full advantage of the
most important asset television has time
while Michael Corleone a went from an
unassuming idealist to murderous
gangster it almost seemed like his
destiny he was part of the family after
all
Walter White however had much further to
fall the medium of television gave the
creator's the time necessary for Walt's
dramatic change by the final season
longtime fans of the series had spent
years of their lives invested in Walter
White's transformation from Mister
Rogers to Scarface the entire series
built up so much tension that the
catharsis of finishing the series is
virtually unparalleled in most other
popular entertainment
the point is Breaking Bad was great
because it understood how to use the
medium it was written in and this
goes for any other format like the early
TV viewers of the 1950's we are living
in the early years of a new medium but
instead of the medium of television ours
is the Internet though some may not look
at the creation of Internet content as
much of an artistic endeavor online
creators are nonetheless making similar
creative decisions about their
cinematography editing and even
narrative structure based around the
medium some are cleverly harnessing
these constraints and using them to
their advantage hello John by now you
have received my message that we will no
longer be communicating through any
textual means like television the
Internet as a medium gave way to a new
set of creative challenges for the first
time the medium itself gave the consumer
the same level of access and
distribution as professional creators
what he has is an internet connection
and a crappy camera from Walmart and
that should be enough and I think right
now because of Technology for the first
time ever that is enough internet
creators don't just compete with each
other like television does with other
shows people producing content on the
Internet also compete with a consumers
own friends and a family this
distinction has shaped the style and
format of Internet content it's the
relationship that young people have with
content that they see online that they
choose to watch versus the content that
they see on TV which is fed to them when
you think of video content on the
Internet chances are you think of
vlogging and that makes sense
vlogging is essentially Instagram come
to life snappily edited visually
engaging videos that show off lavish and
over-the-top lifestyles though the
format is intentionally informal these
creators definitely make careful
aesthetic and thematic choices to convey
a sense of authenticity the genre has
some obvious and cliche tropes handheld
cameras talking directly into the screen
little to no color correction and
day-in-the-life storytelling have become
creative choices these filmmakers use
this aesthetic style originated from a
place of technological limitation but
with the cheaper and better technology
the practical constraints are no longer
there bloggers like david dobrik have
the budget and equipment to shoot their
vlogs like a traditional documentary or
a reality television show but they don't
and that's because they know that the
vlog format plays to the strengths of
the media on the internet content
creators compete with their audiences
own family and friends they keep the
authenticity and lack of polish to make
their content fit in well amongst the
scram stories of the family and friends
you actually know dobrik is a great
example of someone who has really
captured this style his vlogs are
flashily edited and focused on a lavish
lifestyle but at the end of the day they
rely on the authenticity of a group of
friends having fun his episodes feature
a wide-ranging cast of characters each
with a particular brand
damas a player Jason is old and josh is
a washed-up actor the semi scripted
format combines with the authentic
feeling vlog aesthetic blurs the line
between staged moments and reality no
matter how ridiculous the scenario
dobrik has a real knack for making
content that feels like a day spent
hanging out with your friends so it's no
surprise that he's so popular on a
medium that values social networks
blocks like these are successful not
just because they feel real but because
they are hyper real his vlogs channel
the innate desire people have on the
Internet to edit and craft their own
online image to mimic the seemingly fun
and carefree life of dough Berg and his
friends yet it's always crucial that
these vlogs don't feel too produced an
amateur quality maintains that authentic
informal feel and this informality does
not just exist in flogging it's also
popular in other genres of Internet
content I'm sorry it's okay
this invisible we want to give you an
opportunity to communicate a great
example of a format that could only
succeed on the Internet is the long-form
interview podcast while this interview
format definitely borrows from
traditional radio shows like the Joe
Rogan experience capitalize on the at
your own pace nature of the Internet to
explore a topic more fully you can see
and maybe like an interview that isn't
great that like that person doing the
interview is just leaving a lot of
change on the table like maybe they'll
like ask something but because they're
just thinking about the next question
and because this is just some sort of
formula like they're not really looking
at the gas speaking of things Hawaiian
we have to talk about this pineapple
jumpsuit and what we do broken and other
podcast hosts present their interviews
not as formalized interviews but as
conversations the advantage of this
style is that guests relax and often say
and do things they wouldn't normally do
I think when I was I don't know five or
six or something I thought I was insane
ideas get flushed out and we get a
seemingly more honest to look at the
interviewee it's nothing like the
traditional talk-show you can kind of
write you like maybe they kind of wanted
that topic to be explored a little bit
deeper but it's important to remember
that this style is still an interview
tactic while it seems unproduced and
unpolished it's no doubt a conscious
decision on Rogen's part to elicit a
specific reaction out of his guests this
informality authenticity and on-demand
availability makes these shows perfectly
suited for the internet their success
makes sense on a medium where people
expect transparency and love discussion
self-expression and personality thrive
in the podcast format and on the
Internet in general people on the
Internet simultaneously play a character
and act like themselves these podcasts
further blur that line while vlogs
capitalize on the image making of the
Internet and podcasts capitalize on
self-expression a third genre
capitalizes on another equally important
part of the Internet hey everybody
welcome back to another episode of
Kickstarter crafty little stinkers and
welcome back to youtube.com what's up
Greg welcome back to my channel
beautiful bastards don't even a
fantastic Tuesday welcome back to the
philip defranco show
commentary channels are another genre
unique to youtube and to internet
content whether they're political
humorous or dramatic they all take
advantage of the medium in a similar way
like vloggers commentary channels speak
directly to the camera as a way to
incorporate their viewer into the
broader conversation channels like
idubbbz h3h3 drew gooden and many others
engage in pre-existing discussion about
news or internet content if a podcast is
like a social media post em vlogs are
like somebody's profile then commentary
channels are the comments section these
channels constantly respond to each
other highlighting content they find
problematic and engaging in a level of
meta commentary that often requires a
lot of existing knowledge on the topic
it makes sense that content responsive
to audience discussion became so popular
on the Internet television shows on NBC
don't have a comment section
but Internet content creators are
constantly bombarded with comments and
opinions today guys I am reacting to
perhaps the most requested video of all
time
as a result creators often take that
feedback and change their discussions
the highly discursive nature of the
Internet has allowed content creators to
enhance their content
by being a part of the feedback loop
smart creators use this feedback loop to
incorporate their audience into their
content giving them an almost personal
stake in this story the vlogging
podcasts and commentary channels all
vary drastically in style they all
understand the constraints of the
internet and leverage those constraints
to tell a more thematic and engaging
story so what does the future hold for
Internet content who is telling a story
that pushes the boundaries of what the
Internet can do what will be the
breaking bad of the Internet of course
only time will tell but I think there is
one creator who takes advantage of all
the strengths of Internet content Shane
Dawson we should talk about Shane Dawson
Shane Dawson is the king of YouTube
shane toss shane bosu shane dawson is
doing a documentary on logan Paul's
brother Jake Paul okay in the past year
shane dawson has definitely challenged
our assumptions of what internet content
can beat these whole documentary in
series have just been over the over the
top really amazing to see that this has
become kind of a site-wide
event so watch the mind of Jake Paul
like all of it which is weird because
YouTube drama no I had a big part of my
life what I was interested in this
because it looks like we're living at a
time where the entertainment of YouTube
starting to become more legit Shane's
long-form documentaries on controversial
youtubers and conspiracy theories get as
many views as primetime television shows
in a space that's so diverse and
fragmented the videos seem to unify the
community but as of recording this video
it's at 7.8 million views and it's such
a big site-wide event we usually see a
drop in the number of people watching
our video during the first two to three
hours of release of a Shane Dawson video
in these videos Shane Dawson borrows the
techniques of commentary channels
long-form podcast and the vlog to tell
his story like commentary channels Shane
saw the cultural relevance of this topic
and seized the opportunity by entering
something ongoing and incredibly popular
the docu-series was thrust to the
forefront of internet culture not only
did he enter and provide his own take on
the discussion he went to the source
himself creating perhaps the most
complete and valuable entry into the
discussion Shane actively participated
and even edited later episodes to
respond to up-to-date criticism because
Shane is not just releasing
a finished 8 part series he's editing it
and adapting it in real time based on
the response from the community and the
community's responding to his response
and it's a self-fulfilling cycle didn't
never end this technique invested the
viewer in the production of these videos
and this participatory storytelling
suits the internet perfectly then in
another bold decision on Shane's part he
decided to make the series extremely
long form an eight-part series totaling
about 7 hours of content on a platform
known for short snappy videos this
change gave him the time to delve into
the matter thoroughly the informal 1
camera setup coupled with the fact that
he kept roughly one interview per
episode kept his interviewees relaxed
much like how people feel on the Joe
Rogan experience while his conversations
were no doubt edited the internet
allowed him to slow down the
conversation and have a full picture of
the situation providing many different
perspectives finally and most
importantly he intentionally filmed
using vlog aesthetics and editing that
captured the advantages of the medium by
speaking at the viewer Shane engages the
YouTube community in a very YouTube
specific way it seemed only fitting to
investigate Paul using Paul's own format
the vlogger said it gave that same
friendly feel we get from internet
creators like david dobrik the format
stays the same but their lives get
stripped of much of the glamour silence
is not cut out the camera is less
frantic and the subject matter is much
heavier Shane picks apart that seemingly
authentic vlogging style of david dobrik
and Jake Paul and exposes how scripted
and stale those lifestyles can actually
be pretty much everyone that's a little
bit older knows that it's all fake in
doing so he ironically creates something
even more authentic a story even more
suited for the Internet the reason the
series had so much Authority and worked
so well was because Shane produced it so
often Takei at its core it was about
understanding a person and what better
way to do that then as friends hanging
out and having fun together
Shane series might be the first of its
kind I certainly can't think of a vlog
series that's not only so widely popular
but boasts this level of technical and
thematic complexity Shane Dawson has
done so well on YouTube because he
understands the stories the internet
thrives on and the techniques necessary
to tell them so maybe looking at
something like Shane's vlog through the
lens of them
explains why this series was so popular
when it came out and maybe like the
writers of Breaking Bad Shane captured
how to use his medium to craft a message
or maybe the format of Internet
entertainment still has a long long way
to go and people are gonna get sick of
some guy online telling you what to
think but I sure hope not one of the
many benefits of the medium of the
Internet is its accessibility the
drawback is that it's almost as easy to
make low quality content on the Internet
as it is to consume it when it comes to
something like video editing I don't
want to waste time trying to decide what
content is worth learning from if I'm
going to learn a new editing software I
would enroll in a high-quality and
efficient editing tutorial online like
the Adobe Premiere beginners course on
Skillshare Skillshare has over 20,000
high-quality classes on many topics
ranging from editing to creative writing
the first 500 people to click on the
link in the description will get two
months of completely free access to
skill share that's editing tutorials
plus thousands of others from marketing
and video editing to photography thanks
for watching and a big THANK YOU to
Skillshare for sponsoring this video
you